I have been doing high dose IV vitamin C treatments, but feel I need to take a break as my veins
are getting harder to access.
I read this supplement, Valastin Extensicin, can be an equivalent to the IVs.
I think we answered this question last week.
Are you familiar with this and how helpful do you think IV vitamin C is for battling cancer?
Well, I think IV vitamin C can be great for battling cancer.
But I don't think there's anything wrong with taking a break.
I think, like I said, last week, I think giving yourself a break on a therapy for a period
of time can be beneficial.
And I said last week also that this last, I think I have another patient that's taking this
high dose, extensive, and the topical form, and he said he's having benefit.
And I haven't spoke to him for a couple of weeks now.